[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing peter pettigrew aka worm tale
more specifically we're going to be
discussing a popular fan theory in which
he nearly became a professor at hogwarts
before we kick things off i want to say
that i can't take credit for this
particular theory as it has been
floating around the internet for a few
years
however i did want to introduce it to
you guys and let you know what i thought
of it it all starts with the goblet of
fire as this is the book in which
pettigrew would have become professor we
all know that the goblet of fire was one
of the more difficult books for rowling
to write in fact she has professed that
it was the most difficult book for her
to write it had a ton of information a
plethora of new characters and it's the
second largest book after the order of
the phoenix so there was a lot of ground
to cover not only that but it was the
book that required rowling to do the
most rewriting as part way into the
story she realized that she had made a
glaring error in need of rectification
the first three books my plan never
failed me but i should have put that
plot under a microscope i wrote what i
thought was half the book and ack huge
gaping hole in the middle of the plot i
missed my deadline by two months and the
whole profile of the book got so much
higher since the third book there was an
edge of external pressure it turned out
that rowling's big glaring error in the
plot of the goblet of fire was a weasley
character that wasn't destined to stick
around and what exactly was that gaping
hole all about i had to pull a character
there you go the phantom character of
harry potter she was a weasley cousin
she served the same function that rita
skeeter now serves rita was always going
to be in the book but i built her up
because i needed a kind of conduit for
information outside the school
originally this girl fulfilled this
purpose however this wasn't the only
issue with the book or the only thing
that rowling had to rewrite she even had
a hard time getting a handle on the name
of the new book
the title thing was for a much more
prosaic reason i changed my mind twice
on what it was the working title had got
out harry potter and the doom spell
tournament then i changed doom spell to
try wizard tournament then i was
teetering between goblet of fire and
triwizard tournament in the end i
preferred goblet to fire because it's
got that kind of cup of destiny feel
about it which is the theme of the book
and rolling openly admitted that she
rather haphazardly dove into the goblet
of fire immediately after writing
prisoner of azgaban which was one of the
root causes of all of the issues that
she was having
did i oh yes i repaired it this is why
book 4 nearly caused me a nervous
breakdown because for the first time
ever i lost my careful plot which i've
had since 1994 i think i really should
have gone through it with a fine tooth
comb before i started writing and i
didn't i had a false sense of security
because all my other plans had held up
so well so i sailed straight into the
writing of four having just finished
azkaban all of this information is
important because in my eyes it
contributes to the validity of the fan
theory that i'm about to dive into
goblet of fire was the least secure book
during the phases in which it was
written which sort of leaves it open for
greater interpretation
the big fan theory is that none other
than peter pettigrew wormtail was
originally meant to impersonate moody
during the events of the goblet of fire
rather than barty crouch jr crouch jr
did an excellent job at impersonating
moody however we know that both peta
group and bharti crouch jr were involved
with capturing moody in the first place
so i can see just how easily the switch
could have been made now peter pesigru
certainly isn't the most popular of
characters in fact aside from umbridge
and a few awful others he's certainly
one of the worst but the theory
highlights that peter pettigrew is a
pretty important character to the story
he's the one who betrayed the potters
effectively allowing the events of the
prophecy to transpire he's got a close
connection personal relationship with a
multitude of characters and he fought
for both sides the primary argument for
the theory is that barty crouch jr
didn't make much sense as an option and
that pettigrew's character would have
been better situated to have become the
new dada professor one of the primary
reasons highlighted is that out of
nowhere a powerful dark wizard appears
that is strong enough to fool dumbledore
and convincing enough as moody to trick
the whole school and teach a course but
where was this character before all of
this happened suddenly introducing a new
powerful death eater foe and doing away
with peter pettigrew seems almost
counter-intuitive particularly as
pettigrew proves himself to be a worthy
capable wizard in this same book
effectively returning voldemort to his
former glory by himself not only that
but after barty crouch junior's time at
the school is finished and he's caught
he's basically just discarded which is
particularly strange almost all of the
villains in harry potter are simply
repurposed they're not introduced and
then written off like barty crouch jr
and this is where the inconsistency
comes in voldemort always ends up coming
back umbridge always seems to resurface
and pettigrew always seems to escape so
how can this character who had fully
entered the limelight just disappear
effectively what appears to have
happened is that rowling saw no further
role in the narrative for party crouch
junior's character and this to me
suggests that his introduction to the
book was an almost spur of the moment
decision a way of filling a plot hole i
feel like she had plans to make
pettigrew the defense against the dark
arts professor all along but when she
recognized a flaw in her plan the fact
that pettigrew would have appeared on
the marauders map she acted hastily and
had to invent this new wizard to replace
him if you think about it petuku would
have been the perfect person to
impersonate moody he helped the other
marauders create the marauders map so he
knew the school's schematic extremely
well furthermore he had spent time there
in recent years acting as ron's pet rat
scabbers during his formative years at
hogwarts to add to that he had spent so
much time in close quarters with harry
that he would have known a lot about him
certainly enough to manipulate him and
guide him through the tasks of the
triwizard tournament he knew harry's
strengths his weaknesses and he would
have been the perfect undercover agent
particularly as he had so much
experience deceiving people
better gru becoming the new dada
professor also would have been a nice
addition to his character arc as by
doing so he would have showcased brave
qualities of a gryffindor the house to
which he was sorted in response to this
theory some fans have simply pointed out
that rather than creating a new
character altogether crouch jr they
could have just had pettigrew confiscate
the map from harry early on preventing
harry from discovering his true identity
however there are a few issues with this
first of all modi was trying to groom
harry he was trying to get close to him
and i don't think that harry would have
taken kindly to moody immediately taking
his map it would have hurt their
relationship furthermore fake moody only
came into possession of the map after
harry had seen crouch's name on it and
at this stage there would have been
little significance to the name barty
crouch if we flipped that and harry saw
the name peter pettigrew things would
have certainly been shaken up i think
that this is a pretty solid theory but
one thing i want to add is that i've
also seen this idea mentioned around the
internet before but not as a theory as a
way that the book genuinely could have
gone an admission from rowling i'm not
sure if there is any validity to this or
not but i thought it was worth
mentioning what do you guys think of
this one let me know in the comment
section below if you enjoyed the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember
differences of habit and language are
nothing at all if our aims are identical
and our hearts are open
[Music]
you